ja vielen Dank ich bin hier um über den
Iran zu sprechen und unsere Reaktionen
als Europa als mein Europa ich wollte
übern sprechen ein deutscher
Staatsbürger dem die Todesstrafe jetzt
droht ein Urteil wurde getroffen aber
auf dem Weg hierher habe ich erfahren
müssen deswegen bin ich auch ein
bisschen heute neben der Spur dass mein
Pate ich hatte ein Paten der entlassen
worden war frei gelassen worden war dem
nicht mehr die Todesstrafe gedroht hat
gestern Nacht verhaftet worden ist und
unter Folter getötet worden ist das ist
das was tagtäglich passiert jetzt im
Iran es werden Frauen vergewaltigt
Mädchen nicht zufällig sondern per
Befehlskette von niemand anderen als
unseren Verhandlungspartnern als unseren
Geschäftspartnern und die MPS mit
Politik der letzten Jahre übrigens
Partei übergreifend hat versagt
Politik führt zu solchen Taten und wir
brauchen eine neue ihre handpolitik
werden ansonsten
verliert Europa seine Glaubwürdigkeit
und seine Integrität also es steht auch
für Opa viel auf der
was wurde ihrem Paten vorgeworfen
das ist dann diese sind ja immer
man versucht sehr zu Geständnissen zu
zwingen das gab es in dem Fall nicht
dass sie sagen dann immer Kampf gegen
Gott das weil das immer zur Todesstrafe
führt das hat so ein iranischen
persischen Begriff
letztendlich wird es werden da sehr
willkürlich Menschen die bei den
Demonstrationen sind ein Mädchen weil
sie Schokolade Demonstranten verteilt
hat also es wird halt mit Angst gespielt
Demonstranten werden einfach
eingesammelt mehr oder minder verhaftet
in den Gefängnissen gefoltert in der
Regel und ähm teilweise frei gelassen
mit öffentlichen Druck was wir geschafft
haben mit öffentlichen Druck 5 Monate
lang war Iran er wirklich Thema und was
viele eben nicht verstehen sobald der
Druck nachlässt wobei nicht mehr genau
hingeschaut wird
passiert eben so etwas zuerst einmal
unser Beileid dass sie so eine
schreckliche Nachricht bekommen haben
hier auf dem Weg hierher formulieren Sie
einmal ganz klar wie der Druck erhöht
werden kann was genau passieren kann
dass man all die Menschen die Frauen die
weiterhin ohne Kopfbedeckung auf die
Straße gehen Homosexuelle die sich
weiter trauen vielleicht kurz Händchen
zu halten dass wir diese Freiheit
stärken können dass wir diesen Menschen
diesen mutigen Menschen den Rücken
stärken können wir wollen dass die
revolutionsgarten auf die Terrorliste
kommen weil dieser Schritt ist so
wichtig und so groß deswegen wird er ja
auch gerade nicht umgesetzt obwohl wir
eine Mehrheit im EU-Parlament dafür
haben aber die Außenminister Europas
Stimmen noch nicht dafür weil es würde
ein endgültigen Bruch mit dem iranischen
Regime zum iranischen Regime führen und
diesen Schritt ist man noch nicht bereit
zu gehen es gibt Scheinargumente heißt
es gibt juristische Probleme ich habe
gelernt wenn politischer Wille da ist
kriegt man in der Regel hin dieses
Gutachten dieses juristische Gutachten
ist auch nicht offengelegt worden die
Argumenten Völkerrechtler sagen es gibt
kein Problem damit man will es nicht man
will sich nicht mit dem iranischen
Regime verscherzen und das ist auch das
Problem das Regime rechnet damit dass
wenn das Thema abklingt wenn woanders
was passiert wenn wir woanders hingucken
wenn wir Scheindebatten führen über
andere Themen das in dem Moment ist
wieder zurück zu business is usual kommt
das werden wieder Geschäfte gemacht
Deutschland ist der wichtigste Partner
des Irans und das ist ein Problem wir
brauchen eine neue ihre anpolitik die
zeitenwände zu Russland gehört auch ähm
mit einbezogen übrigens zu den
vorherigen Thema gibt's auch natürlich
eine einen einen eine Verbindung dazu
die Drohnen die russland hat werden vom
Iran geliefert einen demokratisches Iran
und den Bevölkerung im Iran ist
demokratisch sie will eine Demokratie
sie ist die haben diese gehen für die
selben Werte auf die Straße für die wir
auf die Straße gehen wir haben die wir
immer propagieren in Sonntag reden einem
kathische sie waren würde im gesamten
Namen Osten für Frieden sorgen es würde
Putin Schwächen es ist so eine Chance
und umgekehrt wenn wir jetzt nicht an
der Seite Menschen stehen noch mal
jumpshy charmant ist ein deutscher
Staatsbürger selbst also jeder Mensch
der getötet wird ist schlimm aber hier
hat Deutschland hier eine Verantwortung
hier hat Deutschland muss doch also auf
eigenem Gebiet sind wir Deutsch Iraner
innen gefährdet sagt der
Verfassungsschutz wir sind gefährdet und
im Leben gedroht und er hat die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft war nicht in den Iran
er hat sich nicht irgendwie fahrlässig
in irgendeiner Form verhalten wenn man
das so sagen weil er ist aufgrund eines
flugzeugpanne in Dubai gestrandet
auf dieser Geschäftsreise dann verhaftet
genau wenn sie sich als
bild-zeitungsjournalistin die sich ja
auch sehr irren kritisch äußert im
nächsten Dubai Urlaub könnten sie
entführt werden
und das erschüttert einen zu tun möchte
ich aber trotzdem in aller Ruhe sagen
beschäftigt sich die Außenministerin
ihrer Regierung
mit der Abhängung eines bismarckbildes
mit der Umbenennung von Sprache und mit
feministischer Außenpolitik also auch da
kriegt man das Schreiben ich glaube dass
dieses Gespräch muss eine Fortsetzung
geben denn auch sie ganz emotional
geschildert wie persönlich sie da
involviert sind das verlangt Mut da
möchte ich Ihnen ganz herzlich danken
heute auch ihnen vielen herzlichen Dank
für ihn für ihren Mut vielen herzlichen
Dank an dieser Stelle für eine lebhafte
Debatte und vielen herzlichen Dank auch
an sie fürs zuschauen bei 8:15 Uhr man
sieht es gut wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt das ist also eine
Verzehnfachung jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie